with hurricane Seasons set to begin on
June 1st we're getting a look at how
scientists are working to protect not
only Coastal communities but also our
national security the Department of
Defense has more than 1700 military
installations around the world along
coastal areas and many of them are
vulnerable to storm surge Manuel
bajorquez has more on a unique
experiment that aims to reduce the risk
of flooding by building structures that
replicate natural reefs
when hurricane Michael roared across the
Florida Panhandle in 2018
[Music]
it made landfall near Tyndall Air Force
base with a storm surge of up to 14 feet
leaving three billion dollars in damage
if our bases are not functioning I mean
Tyndall Air Force Base is still not a
functioning base so that whole Air Force
Base all the things that it did to help
protect our country are not functioning
out of that facility anymore Dr
Catherine Campbell is with the federal
government's defense Advanced research
projects agency or DARPA
it's funding three University research
teams to create hybrid Reef structures
that mimic oyster beds and coral reefs
which can actually dissipate the power
of waves
a type of coral reef defense they've
aptly named refense when a wave passes
over a reef structure it actually causes
the wave to break and dissipate its
energy offshore instead of on the beach
where we have human infrastructure and
buildings and things we want to protect
these are things that can be relatively
easily cast or potentially 3D printed Dr
Andrew Baker at the University of
Miami's Rosenthal School leads one of
the teams they're looking into what type
of structure and material may work best
by testing models in a wave tank
just here in Miami-Dade County coral
reefs are worth something like 650
million dollars a year in averted storm
damages and once you put that kind of a
dollar value on it you actually realize
that we've got to protect these
ecosystems because they save our bottom
line but they are under constant threat
from climate change pollution and
disease so the research here includes
finding creatures and hybrid structures
that appear better equipped to handle
those challenges this is one of the
one of the mall structures that we've
designed for researcher Margaret Miller
it's like creating a new ecosystem it's
not just the coral there's an entire
community that you need around the Coral
in order for the coral to thrive they're
not going to grow in isolation and so
it's a lot of those different pieces of
the community that we're trying to put
together at one time but in order for
refense to work the research has to take
place as far as the country is wide
we're in the Pacific so different
species of coral different wave energy
environments Dr Ben Jones with the
University of Hawaii leads a team of
researchers testing their models at
Oregon State University's wave research
facility
[Music]
they're not only working with other
species but Reef structures that must
endure somewhat different conditions
in our case we have long period high
energy waves that we you know felt we
needed a large distributed system to
help reduce that wave energy
either Coast however storms are altering
the landscape we are getting storms
every year that are damaging our
coastlines and our infrastructure so
this is really something we need to work
at and waiting for coral reefs to grow
back is something we really don't have
the time for
[Music]
a race to protect critical coastlines
using a blueprint provided by nature for
CBS Saturday morning Manuel bojorquez
Miami
fascinated Innovation Innovation is good
yeah nice to replace them even better if
we can preserve them yes yes really
great Point Let's do more of that